hello hello hello st. Louis allo strange
loop I'm so excited to be here y'all
don't even understand there's my first
time in st. Louis my first time in
strange loop I want to thank the folks
that accepted my talk and I want to
thank you for investing your afternoon
to hear a subject about data privacy and
data trust so I want to start by saying
I'm not a lawyer nor do I aspire to be
I'm a product manager basically and so
I'm going to click there we go we're
gonna cover a couple a lot here we're
and so we'll just jump right into it
we're gonna define the the lay of the
land the the evolving landscape of data
privacy we're gonna talk about in the
context of developing software
applications in 2019 what we mean by
data to privacy and what we mean by data
trust I have this concept called the
three C's that we have to consider
that's context context choice and
control and there's a bonus that we're
gonna talk about in the end respect so
at the end of this forty or so minutes I
hope that you'll take away to your
offices or your desks on Monday two
things one what the how we got here what
has happened in the context of data
privacy and data trust where we are
today and what it's gonna be like in the
future secondly I want to sort of weave
this narrative by example
so you actually have tangible and
practical ideas to take with you as
you're building and that as you're
building your software or refining your
your features you understand that weird
your users aren't just shedding
information they're sharing information
with you and and that we need to be good
stewards of their data it's their data
it's my data it's your data right so
let's get into it
the obligatory Who am I and why am I
here I am a veteran I like to think I'm
a veteran product strategist product
manager I've pretty much span the gamut
of anything product from product
engineering to product design product
marketing I've been doing this for about
13 years I for the last seven years have
been focused on immersive technologies
and emerging technologies so the second
link that is not my name as the open AR
cloud which is an volunteer organization
that sort of think about some of these
best practices privacy patterns I like
to call them that we can bring to
augment a'dreea
virtual reality and the open AR cloud or
the augmented reality cloud is basically
like Amazon or Metaverse if you would
for AR if you're interested in that
subject kindly follow us if you're
interested in more of this talk for
kindly follow me who here remembers
Google glass Wow yeah I was one of those
glass holes
right I would prance around back in 2012
being one of the first people in my
little corner of the world wearing
Google glass and given that I was one of
the first people to wear it I would get
a lot of offers to talk about developing
software for Google glass I put together
this ethics and criteria by which people
should sort of govern themselves when
they walked around with Google glass
because if you remember there was a lot
of tension around people walking around
with face computers recording us right
and at one such event when I get invited
to Berlin to talk about designing for
glass wake up in the morning pull up my
computer a little Google Maps I see how
long it's gonna get to the airport pack
you know I order some food hopping the
the uber get to the airport you know and
then I got on the plane and that's why I
put my bags up and I sat down the flight
attendant came to me and says take that
off I go wait what why I've literally
have my prescriptions on here I'm not
like I need these glasses and she goes
you're making people uncomfortable there
is a passenger that is complaining so I
go oh wait a second I went through my
whole diatribe as to how glass worked I
explained that in order to record
everyone technology would have had to
make a breakthrough with batteries right
tinyface computer would have to be on
the entire time which without burning my
face I would actually have to stare at
you the entire time and look like some
sort of creep it will be socially
awkward for me as well she wasn't buying
any of that meanwhile folks around me
whipping out their phones recording this
entire conversation I found it hilarious
so in order not to get kicked off that
flight I took off my prescriptions and I
kept it off for the rest of the flight
that was actually tame compared to other
events that happened to other glass
holes folks got punched in the face in
the middle of the part you know
and so like Subway's and San Francisco
is just awful to people aware and face
computers I've actually heard people
talking about that with ear pods I was
like I will slap somebody's face
straight clean off if I walk around
somebody listening to me or recording my
conversations with one of those ear pods
sounds silly right maybe not because it
was at that point that I actually
started realizing that we were
renegotiating norms as a society it
wasn't about sousveillance me recording
you it wasn't about the ridiculous
concept that I was just coming out of an
airport boarding a plane and the person
complaining would have gone through the
same security surveillance gauntlet that
we all do when we go through the
airport's right so it wasn't about me
recording you it was about the company
Google behind the device what happened
to that data as a as a data subject or
as a normal human being do I have
control over what happens with my
information no do I have the choice to
opt out it's kind of hard physically
even walking around and I have my phone
now you are gonna be you know might be
captured in a frame or two if I am
recording and so it wasn't about
surveillance it wasn't about
sousveillance it was about trust it was
about trust and what happened that
control that choice that context an
awareness so we're gonna talk about that
today because when we build our wares
we need to understand that we have gone
through and are going through new norms
folks are woke around their data right
by show of hands how many people here
feel in control of their data online Wow
okay I'll ask it differently are you
clear on what data is being shared when
you use your banking app Johansson
you're clear that's awesome that that's
that's awesome decision so the data is a
little it doesn't go in that favor
because consumers trust is at an
all-time low
this adversely affects the value that we
deliver to our customers it affects the
success of our products mmm and so we
need to foster an environment of mutual
trust and bridge that trust gap that
exists today it's all I was having this
conversation with someone else at this
conference and I realized at a previous
conference Ori
I realized that humans have always got
it right the first time back in the day
when it costs like three thousand
dollars for five Meg's we were really
really really good at not retaining data
in perpetuity right we would you know I
don't know how old folks are here you'd
have your tape backup you take it home
make sure you have a copy of it outside
the building case there was a fire and
then when you brought it back up it was
wiped right
we only stored information when we
needed it we discarded it when we didn't
we get it right the first time humanity
does think about the electric car
Tesla's
all kinds of new v's roaming around but
we human it a actually rolled out
automobiles with v's this is not new
like we get it right the first time
today data is ubiquitous right so data
is cheap we can store things for free on
Dropbox and so we have quickly found
we've quickly learned as corporations as
apps that if we're able to temper the
velocity the variety and the volume of
data that we have we gain a competitive
advantage so we have to hoard all the
data even if we don't need it let's
define some things before we move on
because I've talked about a couple of
things I've talked about data privacy
I've caught two talked about data trust
I'll be remiss if I don't sort of define
it in context of this conversation to
this audience by the way
show of hands developers in this room
almost everyone designers researchers or
data analysts all right this is a very
engineering skewed room that's great
because I'm gonna tackle this from a
design perspective that wants you out so
what's data trust data Trust is the sum
of data transparency value delivery and
consequence acceptance what do I mean by
that so we all build our apps and we
deliver some ideally some level of value
if it's a painkiller that means your
users can't go a day without using your
solution if it's a vitamin they can come
in and out if it's candy it's a game but
sorts of value being delivered right but
again
Trust is what happens when you sum up
data transparency with it how much
context are you providing your your
users
with that and if you are transparent
with what's happening with that data I
assure you that you earn more trust when
something goes wrong when that
inevitable breach happens right because
you afford the confidence that you the
customer the the the vendor or the app
builder are gonna do right by your
customer
when Tim Apple shows up on the stage I
believe his name is he comes in and
starts talking about the importance of
data trust but then it turns out that
Siri in order to for Siri to be improved
well they have to have humans listen to
subsets of that information that should
be transparent but guess what I loved
him Apple and I love iPhones and and
unfortunately I'm using a Dell but I
love a Mac better and so I accept the
consequence if there is a breach okay so
that's trust when we talk about data
privacy on the other hand that is a
dependency oh that is at the outcome of
trust right and so data privacy we're
not talking about encryption we're not
talking about security so they're
somewhat interlinked we're talking about
control the sum again of control context
choice and respect and we're gonna go
deeper on that here shortly
but we're not certainly not talking
about who owns is this my private data
because I'll give you an anecdote if I
went on 23andme today and I decided to
learn more about my genealogy my lineage
I will shed some personal information my
my DNA and
I will learn about my history well what
if my mother or my brother doesn't want
that information public do I own that
data does my mother
oh that data does 23andme own that data
that is not the context by what you're
talking about we're talking about what
we do when users data subjects share
information with us with consent to
informed consent so let's talk let's
shift gears a bit and talk about where
we are where how we've gotten here we
get breeches every single day
Equifax makes sure that you have to jump
through fire in order to get a hundred
and twenty-five dollars or whatever but
I'm still getting that money okay if
it's 15 don't care it's 15 cents right
now I've drawn my blood and all that
stuff I think is part of the
requirements on article 15 so yes we
know that big data gives us a
competitive advantage and thus there has
been an explosion of data there has been
a rise in the variety of data that we
can use to build valuable things for our
customer there has been a rise in the
velocity the speed by which that data
comes to us and it's the more it is the
better
and we temper that with the volume of
the data that we have and we kind of
want to keep it forever because you
never know when marketing might need it
right
well cause and effect rise in data
horizon breaches well I get breached now
I'm almost jaded it's like ah yet again
OPM Capital One if you you're in the
u.s. the credit card company every other
day
have I been poned calm it's bookmarked
all right definitely check out have I
been tone calm great resource well
that's a data subject as a human being I
hire I I hire I put people in office
right when I vote and though I'd
complain to them and say hey person in
power
your data is also breached go protect us
because the companies don't really have
the ethics to govern themselves so guess
what there's a growth in data
regulations guess what the EU is woke
now if you've ever heard of the GDP are
the general data protection regulation
I'm sure you would I think if you're
playing bingo in this in this talk
you've probably gotten all the checks
well GDP are is a result of years
there's normally a Miss nomer that GDP
are went into effect last year actually
went into into effect in 2014 it was
enforced last year right it actually is
an evolution of other DPAs a data
protection amendments that started in
the UK spilled it into the EU but this
GDP are is far reaching regulation
meaning Aude sitting right there if you
were to hop on a flight Airport hang out
in Brussels for two weeks guess what you
have superpowers
you can require the consent of whatever
information that you know facebook wants
from you I'm gonna pick on Facebook a
lot today you can you have superpowers
you can ask for what information people
have on you you can ask for people to
fix issues with what data they have
exposed to you that you know they have
and you can request for them to purge
that information right and you can bet
that these regulations are set up in a
way that regardless of who you are and
again this is not triangulated to the EU
states this is a long-arm jurisdiction
kind of law meaning if you want to do
business with someone who lives there
you have to comply now when I say comply
there comes the lawyers they go yes is
this feature GDP are complied let's send
out 1500 email
to all of our users back in May 2015 to
let them know that our privacy policy
has changed boom where privacy where
gdpr compliant done
it's not the case it is a burden we look
at that as a burden because for the
longest time developers designers
business owners have looked at the
information that our users shed was a
trade-off it was a zero-sum game meaning
I'm giving you a free service or some
value service that you will pay for
right and so guess what that information
is ours it's my currency well that's
wrong there's some positive some
opportunities that come with sharing
being transparent and providing the
context providing controls and providing
the choice an overall respect of your
users data we talked about personally
identifiable data I've said data about
1,500 times in the short period nine
minutes I'm talking about one or more of
your name addresses emails IP addresses
national ID or if I'm building some sort
of app my you know sensitive information
which is not gdpr compliant but other
regulations have that in in place
sensitive information like place of
birth
race and ethnicity menstrual cycles
those are sensitive bits of information
right you're providing some sort of
value but you should be able to classify
these now how do you do that I want to
sort of before we get into that I want a
sort of summary so we're talking about
context you know how transparent you are
we're talking about control you know how
do you address the growing of sorry yeah
what accessible features do you provide
within your product to to allow them to
control whatever choices you give them
and again that sort of feeds off of each
other okay so we're gonna sort of dive
into each one of those data privacy in
order to afford data trust doesn't begin
when you onboard your user it is
actually the entire lifecycle of your
app right
it starts with onboarding and so let's
look at onboarding for a second these
are some transparency considerations
that your research team or your design
team might you know go through when
they're going through that little design
flow you know discover learn use goal
right I basically sort of twisted that a
little bit to sort of fit how you would
think about building your app with
privacy by design at the forefront
you know how clear are you in
communicating or when your data would be
used these are things this is a question
you should ask as you're sort of your
vision statement for example when it
comes to thinking about context you know
how is is my is is my privacy promise
sort of clearly articulated are there
options for me to provide consent as a
user can I take back consent tomorrow
right do I have that choice how
accessible are those controls how easy
are those controls defined right and
when I do get this information that's
shared right because again it's
positive-sum right not zero so that's
shared do I afford that consequence
acceptance driver do I respect that data
do I treat that data as if I don't
depend that zero zero trust meaning I
don't want to just assume that stripe is
going to just take care of all the
security on the financial part of my app
or that Amazon is just going to be
secure
on the infrastructure side of my app we
see what happened if your fault if
you've been following this space with
Capital One pretty large technology
company tech company you would think
they would know how to Amazon or AWS
turns out they didn't so we're diving
into the first subject context and when
I say context I want some clear reason
why you need my information as one
definition of that context there's
always this joke that I love to throw up
here that Adam and Eve didn't even read
Apple Terms & Conditions and if you look
at iTunes and try to read those terms
and conditions I love Tim Apple by the
way but I'm not reading Macbeth through
and through 20,000 words no I don't have
time for that ain't got time for that so
I'm not reading that nor I'm sure have
any of you right again context also
bleeds into how we design the
information that we gather throughout
the entire journey of every task that we
expect our users to accomplish one
method that I found very useful is
something that I've seen games do very
effectively so this is concept for a
progressive disclosure when I'm filling
out a DMV form online
I'm Biraj dwith a million fields and
that's because I you know as a data
person at the you know the Department of
Motor Vehicles I may need this
information at some point versus the
approach where you progressively collect
that information as there is a need one
example of that is a fictional
restaurant that provides an app to rate
at the end of an experience to rate the
quality of the exit of the ambience or
of the
the food and I get to write it that's a
very simple thing technically you don't
need my name the job to be done for an
analyst is to translate to product or
the engineering team where to improve
the tool in this example do I really
need John Smith's name email birth
certificate social security number
believe it or not people do collect that
but maybe there's added value there is a
justified reason for me to then
re-engage with someone who rated this
very high or rate at a very low how can
we be better
well one medium is email so then
optionally you can provide this little
field here to do that not required it's
good practice there are positive some
opportunities to do good by your
customers they're positive some
opportunities to provide the right
context to your to your users this story
is from is about Facebook I love
Facebook I used to love Facebook I don't
have a Facebook account anymore what
they did right they have this facial
recognition feature that they launched
it's still available in the app today
I'm sure what they did right was
identify a need I'm at this conference
if I turned around and took a selfie
click and shared this on my fictional
Facebook account if I got this gentleman
right here his good side and he's also
on Facebook Facebook would let the
gentleman who's opted into that feature
know hey you were at this location and
someone took a picture guess what you're
in it do you want to tag yourself or do
you want this picture by the way who
owns that picture
anybody Facebook car oh you've read the
terms and conditions good job so uh
that's that's a good need I want to know
right I'm fallible like walking around
the arch and stuff I'm on a little nerdy
scooter Lucas over here was making fun
of me well maybe somebody took a picture
and I've got this nice little move that
I was doing and I'd like to know about
it great need however it the value
delivered was buried in legalese nobody
reads this [ __ ] right and what's more it
was opt-in first surprise surprise and
then you have to go find it and turn it
off there are positive some
opportunities that was wasted and we
have to be bold because sometimes when
we are sharing this information it might
be oh well you're sharing trade secrets
no no just be open first be open first
because people are going to be shocked
Wow
oh my data about where I've walked
around and driven is available on Google
Maps freak out and they read an article
and then just rage tweet Google knows
everything well after that dies off and
you actually sort of see the value you
turn off your location because that's
what the article in that blog said and
then you pull out Google Maps and you
try to find your way around and you
realize it takes five minutes for it's a
triangulate where you are you realize
maybe I should just turn it on so that
outrage has died off after 24 hours
right well I find a history of
everywhere I've been very useful right I
can turn it off when I want I have the
choice I have the context as to how it's
being used at least within the context
no pun intended of this product let's
talk about choice when I
choice I mean do I have agency over my
information over my data I just okay
fine you guys already seen it so I don't
have a Instagram account nor actually I
had to do have an Instagram account I do
love taking pictures
apparently mark Facebook also owns that
company but one other company that they
own is what's up when I did have a
whatsapp account and I was nerding out
on GDP are by the way a bit about me
back to my intro that 2012 event that
sort of just got me focused on on data
privacy was just a catalyst was just a
spark the 2016 elections where we found
out that you know data was you know
certain policies Facebook policies were
violated and a third party actually took
that data and ran with it
Cambridge analytic afew probably heard
was my sort of just just torches and
picked pick axes we're about to storm
the the door I started writing a lot of
articles started given a lot of talks
but I tried to to find what information
at that point what
what's that had on me the only option I
had was to delete my account which I did
I want to be able to rectify any issues
if I know if I have the context and I
want the choice to be able to opt out of
something or another another power of
choice is to be able to liberate my data
right basically you you deserve the
right to sort of lift and take your data
somewhere else right and this is the
apocryphal story of one of the things
that was done right by Google they're
large enough that they do a lot of
things right and they do a lot of things
wrong but being able to provide that
liberation of that data in a format that
your user can actually use right it's
our core control
so that flight that I was talking about
before was to talk about how I built
this fitness app for personal trainers
and personal trainers would you know
prescribed workouts or circuits for
their customers and if their customers
were wearing a face computer or my Apple
watch they could opt in to share
biometric information their pace their
intensity and whether they completed a
workout in order to afford the personal
trainer with additional insights in
order to help you achieve your fitness
goals great idea right but it was scary
we were collecting a lot more
information that we needed tell you that
much if I were to do that over again
let's go through a thought exercise how
would I provide my we've talked about
context and we talked about we're
talking about choice now well for
context at some point if my users needed
a safe state session they would need to
share an email and their name so and
obviously secure it so we provide the
context but controls would be part of my
flow not when they first got to the app
but when they needed to access certain
features of the app so in this case
you'll notice that links fits privacy
consent has not been set up so you
haven't consented yet note that this is
different from the or tracking cookies
yes acceptable right when they do click
on that feature you know that 19,000
word terms of service what I've try to
do here is make this a little bit more
interactive right what I'm trying to say
here is that that terms and conditions
mentions things that we expect to
collect like personal information social
media information cookies well guess
what
I don't really really need social media
information
so then provide the option for them to
take it off this is literally an
interactive version of a Terms of
Service or privacy promise same with
cookies
I need cookies everybody loves cookies
in order to improve the application but
I get to turn that off right it's the
same but there of course I just want to
be clear that there going to be some
functionalities or some terms that as a
business you are justified in collecting
so then disable that all right so say
for example personal information I need
to make sure that no one's sort of
fraudulently using my app so I need some
information and so I've made it very
clear as to what that information is
take this a step further explain further
what that information is used for name
surname and email there are some this is
a pro tip there are some tools that do
it for you some of those tools are one
trust cookie bot NIM nnedi just type in
cookie compliance module but I'll I
don't really know what's happening
behind the scenes because it's ironic
but they're not all so clear as to what
happens to that data so that's a roll
your own is your trust right respect of
your users information but definitely be
inspired by how smarter people than me
have gone about solving this problem
every design or research talk has double
diamonds I'm not gonna anchor too much
on the student in respect of time but
during your problem space when you are
understanding and empathizing with your
users include a what we call the data
discovery do an audit try to find out
the volume understand the volume of your
data understand the variety of data that
you have understand how often that data
comes in okay do what we call a P ia or
a dpi a data protection impact
assessment google it send that to yours
admins your data nerds just have them
just let us know if we do not already
know maybe they already have that
information and then from that do a gap
analysis do a risk register build out a
data lineage map it's gonna look like
spaghetti depending on how complex your
app is but based on that you want to
start cataloging that data there's lots
of tools to help you catalog data now
you're in the solution space you want to
start using tools like calibra or
elation or roll your own with bigquery
and start listening to events come in
that enables your business analysts with
metadata to understand what actual
technical rows and tables are and
whether you changed those and how often
those roles and rows are updated that
allows you to limit and set policies as
to how long you should keep this
information well here's a row that we've
never really needed why is that in our
schematic why do we ever need it and
then someone from marketing goes oh well
in during Christmas we actually need
this information because we're gonna
sell sell them some widgets you go well
when we need it just in time JIT I'm
sorry for all the marketing Americans
some of my best friends are marketing
Americans so I love marketers I really
do know how to sell things that I didn't
build so yes so refine and then ship and
then build your in your implementation
learn and then do it all over again
let's talk about respect that bonus that
I was talking about and it's all about
building that trust up you know what can
you do to show that you're a good
steward of data internally not
externally facing necessarily because
with some of these regulations you're
required to respond 72 hours gdpr for
example 72 hours when there's a breach
and doesn't matter if the processor of
that information like their host is you
know Amazon or as your Google Cloud
doesn't matter Friday something goes
wrong Monday you better be telling an
IEEE CEO or
some data privacy body and in a country
that has been affected right or else 4%
of your annual revenue is a death
sentence or startup 20 million euros
definitely a not a drop in a bucket for
some of these larger firms and every
other day if you've been following some
of these larger firms are going through
a lot of heartburn so I've talked about
GeoTrust I'm not gonna anchor on that
but there's other ways fortunately that
you can glean information from your
customers in order to improve your
application because we're saying oh well
Ford them the control and the context
and the trust and of course you start
thinking well that means I can't really
I don't really know how people are using
my app right in 2006 in 2006 there was a
white paper about something called
differential privacy and before then a
lot of research had been done and Tim
Apple came on stage last year and and by
the way if you say a joke like three
times it kills every single time he came
onstage and talked about how Apple was
improving the iPhone with something
called differential privacy and I got
all my research from the fancy they took
that white paper changed a bunch of
words used a lot of pictures and now I'm
an expert I'm not but the whole idea is
that you can de-identify anonymize data
so if I can actually if I share my
information with you as a software and
you want to be a good steward of my
information one approach would be to
anonymize that information well two
things happen if you have a
vulnerability or something happens where
you have to roll back that data guess
what I really
Netflix a couple years ago decided to
release a massive data set of movie
reviews yes they took an extra step
to de-identify basically and I'm sorry
to anonymize their their data set right
so you don't know that it's Noble who
loves strange love or strange loop
whatever it is and that's a movie right
Ivan had a lot of sleep anyway so and
then of course they scramble the ratings
to just as an actual layer security it
just took a couple months and a couple
of researchers were able to map that two
individuals by mapping that data set
with IMDb's data set so the point of
differential privacy is to add noise to
your data scramble that data at the
point of of the edge on your device
before sending it off to a server and
statistically you're able to sort of
discern trends essentially differential
privacy talked to your statistical
friends they probably can explain it way
better than I but it goes into improving
how your data is used say for example if
you've ever used the Google Maps feature
where you're about to book a show up at
a restaurant and want to book it and
they tell you this is not the right time
to show up here they are able to improve
an add value without tying that to you
or your ID and if you're ambitious and
you know C C++ definitely give
differential privacy a look on github
it's been open sourced so yeh landing
the plane now I promised I was going to
talk to you about consent because
affirmative consent being collecting
consent and this picture would make
sense in a second I promise collecting
consent is very important it ties to
that trust right
it's highs the the data the the context
you know I'm able to know what I'm
consenting to because it's transparent
I'm able to provide the controls to my
user so that
can actually opt out and say I do not
consent right and in the choice
obviously that comes with that action to
control so I'm not going to
recontextualize my the way I think about
consent and why I think consent is the
most important subject when it comes to
rocking the concept of data privacy this
is my daughter I can't tell you her name
and she lives with me I put her in the
care of teachers caretakers to show her
a good time to teach her and to feed her
that is the agreement I am the parent
that's not controversial right standard
however if the teacher school wants to
go outside of the bounds of this like
take my daughter to the theme park or
the swimming pool or give her some
different kind of food than I've done I
have signed off of they come to me
why because I'm the parent right you get
it see where I'm going with this it's my
data right as a user if I share that
with you Facebook use it for the terms
that we agreed upon and if you should
use it for outside of the bounds of that
agreement like share it with Cambridge
analytic oh I think I should know and so
this is a call to arms the call to arms
are basically asking you in this room to
bill bake in context control choice and
overall respect of your users data
because guess what is not your currency
it's ours the users the data subjects
okay this is the future that we want to
build because our users are getting
jaded we're losing so much value because
we do not respect our data our users or
their data that is unfortunate and the
market will judge us
based on how we respect our users data I
will make these slides available this is
where I got a lot of my research nest
privacy framework I Triple E obviously
they've read a lot of the gdpr and to
end over wine we give the Canadians
credit for privacy by design and
Kevorkian and and others I'm a big fan
of make Nathan Kinch this is a name that
you should look up if you're nerding out
like me on data privacy and you're as
passionate about the subject and again
tensorflow Google's open source the data
privacy library and of course you can
use tensor flow and machine learning
library to do that so thank you and stay
woke